what is it Eve is me this kind of was
time to get into that that area of
mathematics of one of the areas of
mathematics or it's like it's just death
by notation and I can't even get started
I can't even access these questions
because I can't I don't know what this
means you know the whole point of
notation is to boil things down so
they're super succinct and super concise
but when their dad to sing from that
concise it doesn't give you all that
many clues if you don't have prior
knowledge about what any of the notation
me so what does this mean right this
means I've got a function I'm just
calling it f I could call it G or David
or eggs or whatever I want right it's
just a name and what I'm going to put
into the function the particular input
that I've got is on his exes right again
there could be anything right the
example I gave you last week was a
function that you guys have known for a
long time this function is the area of a
circle right it doesn't take X's as
inputs I mean we could make it exes if
we wanted but we call it our why do we
call it off because it stands for the
radius right so you might as well give
it a meeting for labor morning ok so all
this means is i have a function that's
what its name is that's what inputs I
put into it and this is the rule that
will tell me how to get from those
inputs to those outputs ok it's simple
stuff all right so then when you see
this what this means is what you've got
in the brackets is well what would you
like right like X is any input but what
specific value would you like me to try
ok one so let's let's give a crap shall
we from 1a I read that as f of X so I'm
going to read this as f of 1 right so
I'm going to say f of 1 equals now I
could just do a straight valuation I can
check this into my calculator well it's
actually helpful because you want to
demonstrate you understand what function
notation is I'm going to pop it straight
into this I'm going to straight
substitution even though it's relatively
easy to actually calculate right so you
can see all i've done is i've replaced
all my ex's here which might include and
i've replaced them all with one because
that's the particular input that I want
to try
okay and from there i'm just going to
crunch the numbers um one ladies two
plus five what do you get don't over one
be all at once guys okay it's good only
for isn't it 1 plus 5 and 6 take away
too there you go easy types right when
you have a look at B and particularly
chosen it because when you've got
negative numbers in there good morning
these follow the same rules as what we
had a look at before but there are some
easy traps to fall in so I'm going to
evaluate F of negative 2 but just like I
did at the very top line when I
evaluated at 1 right I'm just got to put
in each number and in what we I'm going
to put in brackets to help me recognize
right but classic era that many students
will make is that they love don't look
at this X square and they'll say well I
want negative 2 so it'll be minus 2
squared except minus 2 squared is minus
and then for which is 2 squared but in
fact the negative that might assign it
also gets squared so what happens so we
get square yeah just because it
backwards negative 2 times negative 2
there two negatives in this and that's
for their treating is in here as well
that's another 4 plus 5 so that gives us
there it's wrong all right happy times
now just last one on this first function
right is these are particular values I
want to try okay well there's no reason
why I can't put more algebra into it if
I want to and as you'll see you later
this lesson there are very good reasons
why sometimes I want you okay so are you
getting sick of it yet when I do fo3 a
all I'm doing is I'm taking that first
function everywhere I see an X I'm going
to put in the 38 I think so I do it like
this 3a or square minus two lots of 3a
plus 5 it's all there is to it okay I'm
the brackets they help me again realize
oh it's not just the a that gets squared
the 3a is the whole input so that's why
this first term because
9a squared very good so you've got your
index laws happy there I this is going
to be minus six a plus 5 and as it
happens we'll you can't do it into that
that's not XP okay right let's move on
to this next one are where we're
throwing in an exponential there which
is a bit tricky like all remember in
victuals either let's let's have a go of
these questions oh hey so this is a new
function really should you give it a
name that I was lazy when I do f of 0 in
this case Oh again I'm going to replace
all of those X's in that line there with
zeros so I get three outside of 2 to the
power 0 plus 0 okay now recall your
index box right what's any number raised
to the power of 0 and what's an equal to
a sequel of one good so classic era is
ah it's a bit like 2 times 0 actually
it's nothing like two times zero that
would be 0 so this is 1 plus 0 so our
answer here is three okay with that yeah
well you have a going to be again
because i'm giving you strange numbers
here you need to know your index Morse
fairly well of f of a half give you
three lots of 2 to the power half plus a
half okay yeah feedback indices where
you got fractional indices what is
what's our definition into the power of
a half now it's going to be rude to now
not all of you jumped out to tell me I
its route to more immediate obvious to
you so let me just rehearse why it
should be it's like oh that's what it
has to be if I gave you this I've got a
pair of numbers same base right so a
that number the bottom and i am
multiplying them and they've got indices
right what do i do to these listens i'm
going to add the bar type i multiply
these two numbers I add the indices okay
so I get something like this and the
reason why is because I'm how sad it had
to queue times 25 right 2 cubed is
really two times two times two and to
the fives really two times two times two
times two times two so how many choose
do I have the answer is eight right so
I'm adding those
together that makes sense okay now when
we don't know what something is when we
try out different values so if I said
well I don't know what to the half is
right like what is that actually equal
to well taking advantage of what you
just told me if i multiply super half by
itself no if I multiply it by itself
then according to this I just I just add
those indices don't know okay good
morning that's okay you want to just
serve I got one table here just come
around that way let's see my father now
what we just say I add the indices are
you dare to 21 okay now hold on a second
to the one is just too right so what's
that number that when you multiply
itself multiplied by itself gives you
two and the answer is it's going to be
with you that's in fact that's the
definition of what the square root of
two is number you multiply by itself
you'll get to sew up in here I'm going
to say that's three times the square
root of two once a half can I do
anything else to this I mean it's just
slightly simpler not a huge amount but
you know if I if I expand this I can
just say well that's 3 mu 2 plus 3 on 2
sides like root 2 are famously
antisocial that can't mix with the other
numbers so you're just gonna leave it
that's it that's as simple as it gets
okay that was be now we're going to do
the last one and I've got on the on the
board and this one you got some more
algebra in there but be careful because
this algebra is a little bit stickier
just again has to be careful with your
evaluation of this so when I go F of 1
minus a okay first I'm just going to
take all the X's and replace them like
this okay so here comes my substitution
stuff it's 3 times 2 to the power 1
minus a plus 1 minus a are you happy
with that okay um
is there anything I can do with this
thing hmm I can do some expansion cone i
can multiply this three by all of these
terms okay and I will in a minute just
like I did here but before I do that
just like when i went from this line to
this line and this line to this line i
kind of want to interpret what on earth
is happening with these indices inferior
right this index to the power of that
we'd miss what does that actually mean
it's strange okay now again I'm going to
hijack this thing right if you told me
this there is a corresponding thing that
happens with division right if I'm not
multiplying numbers makes a mess but if
I'm dividing them what if i said well
okay i want to find a question rather
than the front what does the index lore
tell us i subtract right just like this
and this are opposites right inverse
functions in fact our this and this plus
they said they're opposites okay you
happy with that idea now can you see
that what I've got there into the whoops
it is it uses the same end of the n
minus M that's kind of like what I've
got I've been here you see I've got a
subtraction right so what that means is
that is a contraction of something
that's being divided okay i want to go
kind of in Reverse now i want to go back
to this thing okay and that will be
alike so what division is actually a for
ancient three times what what two things
are being divided one good so the two
nother one is the thing out the front
there it is they correspond and when i'm
dividing by a is this really a very good
okay then I've got this guy just hanging
out on the side now I generally just
like we don't like having negatives on
like the bottom of our fractions and
that kind of thing we tend not to like
negatives in our indices as well as
you'll discover later on there are
sometimes reasons when you want that but
usually not negatives even get rid of we
will I'm to the power of one that's just
ok so now if i want to i could multiply
this whole thing through I could get all
the denominator Center nominated if I
wanted to make it all one fraction but I
don't have to i think i'm pretty happy
with that ok if you're interested I mean
the next life possibly could be you know
it's also equal to 6 plus 3 times 2
minus 3a times to the a all over today
but can you see why I didn't really go
to that line like does that look simpler
to you I don't think there's a leverage
advantage ok so I think leaving here is
on this one